hi we are here with Hy today thank you
so much for joining us to talk about
your music and your beauty businesses
thank you for having me I want to start
with your music career though you are an
award-winning musician a Grammy nominee
walk me through what it was like to
realize that you could sing and act at a
young age oh my goodness um well first
of all thank you for having me uh it's
funny listening to you say all those
things I'm kind of like uh oh yeah gosh
that is a lot of stuff huh I'm like
maybe that's why I'm tired all the time
um I was just having this conversation
with uh with one of my good friends
yesterday actually and I was uh telling
her I was like I remember the first time
someone ever told me that I had a nice
voice um I think that's one of those
memories that kind of like stays with
you especially when it ends up becoming
you know part of your line of work and
um I was in like in the car I was
singing along to probably an AV LaVine
song cuz that's the arrow right um on
the radio and my mom turned to my father
and and said Chris listen to her and my
dad was like what and she was like she's
good and I just remember you know the
way that felt and how proud I felt in
that moment um I think kind of spawned
me having The Bravery to to try to sing
out loud to not be embarrassed um
naturally when you become a teenager
that all walks completely back because
you become embarrassed of literally
everything
um and that's really when I started
writing cuz I singing then became a more
private thing for me so I was in my
bedroom kind of like writing songs and
you know performing them quietly with my
little brothers like screaming down the
hallway like shut up you suck um as
little brothers too yep I have two
little brothers so I get it yes yeah
they were like my biggest fans now so
it's great but um I wanted to be a
painter that was my dream profession
uh music was a hobby and um After High
School I you know I was an AP student
and I was year book editor and uh I was
in a bunch of extracurriculars and you
know I um intended to go to uh like a
pretty I guess a pretty like a claimed
University and uh I was 17 when I
graduated high school and found out that
uh I could not afford to go um which was
something I knew it wasn't a surprise to
me that my parents you know didn't have
uh a lot of money at all but being 17 I
couldn't really apply for loans or I
couldn't really take matters into my own
hands and uh I was really frustrated
because everyone had told me my whole
life you know if you take these classes
you get good grades you do these things
you'll go to a good college etc etc and
that was like life kind of hitting me in
the face of like it doesn't go that way
sometimes and that was my big moment of
like well what do you mean I did
everything right and so from that moment
forward I was just like oh I'm just
going to do everything wrong cuz doing
everything right doesn't matter so I
moved to New York I didn't go to college
at all and then
uh I started making music and I just
sort of never looked back it was uh a
very impulsive career choice but it just
I was receiving such positivity and so
many opportunities were snowballing from
it that there it would have been crazy
to not keep going
definitely and it's one thing to have
music as a hobby and as something that
you do you know in in private or in your
own time it's another thing to realize
like this is a viable career option for
me it's a business that I can build for
myself so when did you first realize
when did that click that this could be a
viable and long career you know I want
to tell you it was when I signed my
record deal because that was the largest
amount of money that I had ever been
paid for my work like at any given time
um and I think it was that I think
because I I had uh some really really uh
important people in my life who made a
distinction to me early on that became
Paramount in the way that I perceived
you know being an entrepreneur who's
also an artist and is dealing with like
you know spiritual personal abstract
material in a sense um and it was when I
received my record deal and I was like
wow I can't believe you know they're
giving me so much money and somebody was
like they're not giving you money they
were like they're lending you
money which is a big distinction um and
they're doing it in exchange for goods
or a service you are earning this with
what you are you know what you're giving
them to
distribute um and that distinction was
really important to me I think because
otherwise I I I find the lines do get
blurred um in my industry
specifically um where you have to remind
yourself cuz making music feels like fun
you know you don't realize that you're
all the time that you're
uh you're getting paid in exchange for
that that service or or that those goods
and and that was important to me because
it allowed me to compartmentalize being
an entrepreneur and being an artist and
realizing that I wasn't an artist who
became an entrepreneur and stopped being
an artist I was an artist who also then
became additionally an entrepreneur so I
had to nurture the art part of me
separately from that that other part
right because those are business
transactions along the way abely so
being an entrepreneur you you know
obviously have your musical career and
your musical brand but you also ventured
into other avenues of entrepreneurialism
you have a beauty brand now about face
and AF 94 walk me through your decision
to enter the beauty space specifically
you know with your platform you could
have gone gone in many different
directions so why Beauty you know I
makeup has always been a really
fundamental part of you know what I do
it's
obviously uh it's a focus of so many
elements of my career whether it's like
me getting on stage or doing a photo
shoot or you know a music video
makeup it says a lot it it describes an
unspoken part of you and it defines the
way you're presenting yourself you know
to the world and because people are so
visual even though they're receiving the
music they're also making assumptions or
developing opinions kind of based on
what you look like when you are
presenting them the music and it also
affects the way that you feel when
you're doing a performance you know
there's a reason why makeup has like a
long-standing history is being a part of
like battle theater religion ritual um
because it really does have this
transformative ability not just from an
optical point of view but from like the
person who's stepping into the makeup um
I do my own makeup and I started doing
my own makeup mostly out of necessity
City my first um record company was a
boutique label from New York called
astroworks and uh their whole roster was
DJs was like male electronic artists um
so that initial conversation was really
funny when it started becoming like yeah
I need styling I need Glam I need this
and they were like you have $20 the guy
the other guys are showing up with the
USB in like the hoodie and doing the
thing um and that was like a moment
where I realized I didn't have access to
the same resources as some of my other
peers especially my female or like
female presenting peers and so I um I
was like okay well I'm not going
to fall behind I just need
to figure out how to do it
myself um and so I've always loved
makeup but that was when I had to get
like uh technical about it and I had to
learn about the way that I was looking
on a red carpet or on stage and there
was a lot of failures at first first
some photos I look back on and I'm like
oh dear okay um but then I found you
know that I was taking kind of my skills
as a painter which is you know what I
wanted to to do with my life and
applying them in this way but most
importantly it was giving me control and
autonomy over my face um I had worked
with makeup artists earlier in my career
when those resources started coming in
and I could actually afford one and I
just kept finding that I didn't look
like myself I didn't feel like myself I
didn't look like myself and that really
compromised me when I was going out and
having to uh bear myself in in in a way
that I've promised will be authentic you
know to my audience um so I just sort of
took matters into my own hands and
through that I just learned so much
about it you know like I just developed
an encyclopedic knowledge um of makeup
because I've used it
and sort of documented the way that
certain products perform certain
ingredients perform under every possible
you know scenario um so with that being
said I was actually approached by um the
founders of hard candy which was one of
my favorite makeup brands ever as a as a
kid because it was so brave and it was
kind of makeup for the alt kid
um in a time where there wasn't really
anything like it and it just we just
felt like the perfect pairing to to do
this thing
um and I had a real motivation to make
products quite frankly that would just
work for me that I couldn't find on the
market you know so that's come kind of
where some of our initial Innovation
comes from was just like personal need
personal necessity again necessity um
and it just felt like such a natural
thing to do you know it just really felt
like a natural thing to do um because
it's just a deep love of mine yeah yeah
but in a product based business where
people are going to you know invest
money into what you're giving them and
and really put a lot of trust into you
I'm sure that you felt a lot of
responsibility to like provide those
offerings that you wish that you had you
know growing up through your life and
then through the music career what were
some of the initial steps that you took
to ensure that the ingredients were on
par that The Branding was on par you
know like there are so many things that
that really it it it takes so many
things to build a business and build a
brand that people resonate with so what
were some of those initial steps that
you think were crucial well I didn't
sleep in the beginning um especially
because I was simultaneously touring my
third album while we were um developing
about face and uh you know I mean to
this day and especially at the start
when we were developing our initial
product line before launch um I was
meticulous about
formula um I
review every formula you know past it
starts with the initial Innovation you
know which is is like I I would like to
see a product like this or I would like
to see this product but see it function
in this way um then comes the formulas
they come back to me and um some of them
are fast some of them are I'm like I
love this this is incredible let's get
going and then some of them take a
little bit more time you know I kind of
compare it to when I'm making a record
and I do mixes you know cuz sometimes
it's great but there's like one little
thing that's throwing it off so you have
to send it back to the mixer and be like
ah like I don't know is it the is it the
EQ is it the drums is it the this you
know and the makeup process is really
similar from like a formulaic
perspective where it's like um is there
too much hyaluronic acid you know like
is it uh you know is the product to
viscous um is like the opacity of the
pigment sort of not Distributing
properly especially because we deal with
you know vegan ingredients and all of
them are clean as well um so just really
meticulous doing that and then also
wearing the
products over an extended period of time
not just testing them once deciding I
like it and sending it away you know
seeing how does this work on stage when
I'm sweating and I'm under the lights or
you know how does this work um how does
it photograph you know that was a big
one is how does it photograph and
spending Real Time with the products and
making sure that I really loved them um
and then from that point it comes my
favorite part well product development
is definitely one of my favorite Parts
but you know getting to play around with
such
a a large catalog of items from a
marketing perspective is really fun I
get to try a lot of ideas that don't
necessarily make sense like you know
from the music point of view
um it's really I think about for me
about keeping a sense of fun about it
um feeling um like hunger and gratitude
you know wanting feeling lucky that I
get to do it so making it fun you know
inviting my my friends over most who
work with me or work with about face and
us just like you know having a glass of
wine and like going through shade names
and coming up with like the you know the
most fun or silly or clever ones that we
can um but I have a real uh I think
protective mentality over it because I
know the market is so oversaturated so
it's really important to me that every
has my personal DNA on it and also that
it feels uh it feels like there's a
purpose or Reason rather than why are we
just making more products in a in a
world where there's already so many of
these products is like you know it has
to have a a singular identity kind of
definitely and I want to talk about the
clean aspect of the brand because I
think that is something that is
identifiable with about face what are
some of the steps that you have to
ensure are checked off or that you go
through to make sure that every product
is clean what does clean mean to about
face an AF 94 what are the metrics that
you really are facing that off of
there's a standard you know so there's
like a basically a uh a a large um
database of of products that have been
or ingredients rather that have been
tested and and proven you know to um to
be
clean it's difficult when you start
Crossing
into it's it's funny it's a
it's a lot like um it's a lot like uh um
like print media you know where it's
difficult when you start Crossing into
how does it react with the particular
individual's sensitivity you know um but
generally speaking um everything is is
tested against that that database to
make sure it's not including any uh
previously recognized you know reactive
ingredients um and then in addition to
that there are you know other just kind
of Baseline
safety uh laws in place you know a lot
of our products we use vegan pigments in
the eyes but then we have to be sure
that that vegan pigment passes the
ocular test meaning that it's safe for
the eyes um so it's really just about
finding the right balance um our product
development team is exceptional they are
just the best like I just get so excited
um to talk to them every time I get the
chance to so from a a grander point of
view it's it's being tested and there's
also like you know some authorities in
place for that like there's a really
great website actually that has uh you
can type in a product and it'll tell you
like on a scale of 1 to 10 basically how
clean something is because it's not so
black and white it's usually just you
know but for us we want to be pretty
high up on that um that clean barometer
and it was really important to me
because I I have an autoimmune disease
so my skin is really reactive
and uh it's certainly wonderful to be
able to wear products and to make
products that I can actually wear
totally you know um so this's a little
bit anecdotal I think experience in that
in that um in addition to you know the
the industry standard definitely and my
last question I have for you is what is
next for you do you have any big plans
with the beauty brands with other
entrepreneurial adventures with your
music I would love to know what you're
looking forward to in the next couple of
months or year oh my gosh I uh let me
tell you I am doing a lot of things
right now and because of the gestational
period of some of the particular
industries that I'm like a part of it's
just the worst because I just want
everyone to know and have it and
experience it right away um so the
weight time is just really torturous it
it is um and I find especially as you
know as my career grows um and sort of
the magnitude of the things I'm working
on grow that weight time just gets
longer and longer because there's so
many moving parts and you know there's
so many details to the execution I'm
definitely working on music but I'm kind
of always working on music but uh right
now I'm working on music uh
intentionally and uh you know about face
has um a ton of really really exciting
launches coming in the next year and
some retail expansion uh same for AF 94
um I'm raising my son which is amazing
he uh just turned two a couple months
ago um so I'm navigating that and uh
having the pleasure of like inviting him
into some of these worlds you know he's
starting to really Express an interest
in music and he loves makeup oh that's
amazing he just loves it and you know
it's funny uh from a nature vers nurture
perspective I guess I was always kind of
wondering I was like oh does he love
makeup because I do or and then I
realized that just I worked as soon as I
pretty much as soon as I gave birth I
was right back to working so he spent
the first like year of his life like in
my arms while I was doing my makeup with
one hand so like naturally yeah so
naturally he's interested in it um but
he was doing my makeup the other day and
like I said he's two and he was putting
highlighter on me and he did my cheeks
and he stopped and look at me and went
to just do the tip of my nose he knows
and I was like that's a trick how do you
know that I was like that's a trick
professionals use like yeah you're
genius makeup genius um yeah really I
think just trying to
uh continue all the amazing Pro um
projects that I have going right now and
integrating all that into into
motherhood and enjoying the last year of
my 20s you know I got one year left
until I start the big the big 30 um but
I'm looking forward to being the baby of
a decade yeah you know the grandma of a
decade right now I can't wait to go be
the baby of the next one um and see all
that has to offer me and
uh I think
uh I started doing this when I was 18 um
and I felt so old at the time and I've
been doing it for over a decade now um
so sometimes I just feel ancient um and
I've realized I think this past year
just how young I really am um and that I
have such a such a long runway in front
of me to try new things and explore
different things and uh I'm going to try
them all because I I wasn't supposed to
I don't think that I was really supposed
to be here you know what I mean I kind
of have that that thing a little bit
where I look around the room and I'm
like oh
gosh this is a total it's a total glitch
they let me get this far so while I'm
here I'm just going to try to cause as
much trouble as I possibly can and do as
much you know fun amazing stuff with the
with the opportunity yeah well you're
here you're doing amazing things and I'm
so thankful that you sat down with me to
talk today we can't wait to see
everything that's coming in you know On
Your Horizon so thank you so much of
course thank you